what's up everyone Anna and Dave with
you we're just kicking back we're
drinking some brewskis having a good
time and I wanted to talk to you a
little bit about Lord Lord was in Kansas
City Missouri and i'm not talking about
our Lord Jesus Christ I'm talking about
using every way he's absolutely that guy
he's watching you and judging you he has
not been resurrected however uh Lord was
performing in Kansas City Missouri love
her music do you like her music Oh like
the Lord oh do you feel like the Lord
lover do you feel that you'll never be a
royal I'm probably not all right do you
know my reference or no okay anyways
which probably really means I'm not
gonna be it I know you like that selfie
song how about that that has nothing do
nothing to do with me okay yeah so so
she's performing and the Westboro
Baptist Church always loves to protest
at like random events because they like
to get attention well congratulations
you're getting a little bit of our
attention in this case the reason why
I'm bringing this story up is because
while they were doing a protest and of
course the one issue they care a lot
about is the gay issue they want to take
away gay rights as much as possible or
make sure that they never get any rights
in some states yeah um as they're doing
their protest there was a counter
protest and they made a reference to
Fred Phelps who's the founder of the
church and who recently died for natural
causes and the sign just said sorry for
your loss and I actually thought that
that was a really really great way of
doing a counter protest yeah I mean it
was it was brilliant because it's in
it's taking literally what religion is
supposed to be ya know you mean like
turning the other cheek yeah and and
being better and forgiveness and all
that good stuff and putting it out right
there so it was it was pretty amazing
but the whole bud Westboro Baptist
Church I mean there the whole thing do
you think it's gonna crumble now I about
him um I don't know if it'll crumble
without him I think eventually it'll
crumble because people are becoming more
and more in favor of gay rights so
eventually I think it will but I don't
think it has anything to do with Fred
Phelps I think it has more to do with
changing ideology and mental
and that's a great thing that means that
we're progressing when it comes to this
particular issue but I did a lot of
research into fred phelps past and he's
a really interesting guy or was an
interesting guy apparently in the 60s he
was a civil rights lawyer which is so
ironic he would represent a black
clients which is insane because you
wouldn't think that he wouldn't do that
he seems like the most hateful guy but
um he his family would get attacked
regularly because he would try to
maintain the rights of his black clients
and people would call him an n-word
lover and whatever and and he just had a
really colorful past and then he went on
to hate gay people yeah do we know what
happened that caused that I don't I
really don't know I have no idea what
changed in his mind Jake thinks he had
some sort of mental breakdown but who
knows maybe he he he believes or he buys
into the notion that people make a
lifestyle choice when they're gay right
and when it comes to your race obviously
you're born that way when it comes to
your sexuality obviously you're born
that way and even if you chose a big
damn well yeah I mean yeah and if you
did who cares but that's a sidebar but
you know what I actually think that the
Westboro Baptist Church in a weird way
has been good for the gays and for the
gay movement because they frame the
people against the gays as such fringe
lunatic yes but I think it actually
strengthened the pro-gay the lobby you
know cuz there's a big gay lobby oh no
but but the people that were fighting
for gay rights I think we're actually
strengthened by seeing their their
lunacy up absolutely I agree with you
one hundred percent well let us know
what you guys think what do you think
about the Westboro Baptist Church do you
think that it's going to be around much
longer do you think it's gonna crumble
that's what we're all hoping for and
what do you think about their First
Amendment rights should they be able to
do these types of protests at the the
funerals of our fallen soldiers they do
that quite regularly should we should we
toast to Fred Phelps yeah let's listen
we're gonna miss you a big guy we don't
know what happened there but you know